it's been the hardest secret of my life
i have to tell you
it's um it's been really hard i think
that it's been even harder for my father
who is such a massive fan and and um
loves his facebook
so it's yeah it's i'm excited to see
what everybody thinks because she truly
is so special and she's been such a
pivotal
character in this world and she's so
important to
to the story in mandalorian um
and and where it's going and um
i think it's important she's important i
am bogotan
of clan crees i was born on mandalore
and fought in the perch
i am the last of my line katie slackoff
at the time that we're talking
the show has pretty much just premiered
this episode
and so people are like reacting to it in
real time how do you feel right now
you know it's pretty surreal to be
honest um
i've really tried to stay off social
media because i have not seen
the episode so i'm really just trying to
um
um
for the most part you know this
character has been such a part of my
life for so long
and um it is incredibly special and rare
to have been able to actually
be able to play her in live action and
and um
um so there's a lot of nerves that come
along with that
so walk me through like when did you
find out this was happening you get this
call or conversation with dave or john
and they're like not only do we want to
put bokeh tan in the show
you are going to be playing her we want
you to play her
it was such a surreal moment you know
it's um
i would have to go back and look at my
tweets because i actually tweeted this
has been like the biggest day of my
entire career
um you know my dad raised me on on
sci-fi and star wars and so um
this is like a dream come true playing
her in clone wars within rebels was a
dream come true
this is insane um but i you know when
mandalorian when the news of the
mandalorian came out um
i sort of thought to myself in the back
of my mind you
you never know um i knew that it
probably wouldn't happen fan castings
never happened
um and so i sort of slyly mentioned it
to dave filoni when i saw him
at one point and he was like well you
never know when his cheeky little way
that he does it
and then when i got a phone call that to
sit down um
with john favreau i think my brain
exploded
um and i sat down sort of thinking that
i was going to take this meeting and
and really have to like jump through
hoops and i walked in and and
it was it was pretty surreal he was like
do you want to do this
and i was like i don't even i didn't
even know how to answer the question of
course i wanted to do it i was such a
huge fan of the show and then
this is pretty pretty amazing i know
that's kind of a big question but what
does bokeh tan mean to you you have been
playing her for such a long time like
what does she
mean to you out of all the characters
that you've played i have said for the
longest time that
i would have played a rock in star wars
just to be part of the world
i said that i think from the beginning
of my career um
and so when when boca tan came around it
was
it was just an opportunity to exist in
the world and
to really just live out a childhood
fantasy and imagination and over the
years she's become
very important to not only myself
because i've played her for so long
and and i've really seen her grow up as
a character
um and and she just means a lot to me
you know she's been the character i've
played the longest and
um um it was really interesting
translating her onto live action it was
it was pretty crazy so the first day
that you
i don't know if you're doing like a test
or whatever like the first time you
see yourself in the full live action
bokeh tan
look what was that like was it emotional
how did you feel
i did cry um did you not
yeah dave dave was there fellaini and
and
he just he he and i were both just
blown away she she looked so
much like the bogotan that we had come
to know and love
um and they did such a brilliant job
with her
that um i i i think we were both
just it was very surreal it was really
surreal
um it it sort of felt like the
culmination of a 25-year career where
i've been working so hard and
and to actually have this moment that
that seemed so much bigger than anything
that i could imagine
um blew my mind we've seen like the
animated version for so long was there
something that was really important for
you to be like i
want to get this part right in the live
action version
you know it might seem really crazy but
bogatan has the scar
on her face um and i was really attached
to that
i was really attached to her freckles i
was really attached to how her eyebrows
point down um in just the weirdest
way where it was finding the animated
version of it which is a bit
cartoonish in the sense that they go
down such at such a
point and then finding and translating
that into
a real person and making sure that it
didn't look cartoonish
um was really fun i had such a great
time
um in the makeup chair figuring out her
look but
i really just wanted her to be
everything that fans of the clone wars
and rebels wanted her to be in every
sense of the way i wanted to make sure
that she
moved the way that she did in rebels
that that she
you know that she had all of all of who
bogatan was baggage and all
um in the way that she carried herself
well because there is like there's so
much time
unaccounted for and now we have so many
more questions so
i mean how what would you say has been
the biggest change in her
since the last time we saw her because
she does seem
a little different like obviously she
really wants something back
you know i think that there is a little
piece of bokeh tan
that i don't think you see coming
she's got something else going on in her
mind
and she is very um
everything she does is purposeful um
and i think that that is new for her um
you know she's
she's grown into the role of a leader
um and i think she finally believes that
that she is that leader um but there is
there is an
ego that comes with that with her um
that may or may not um
work against her so season one of the
mandalorian when you're watching it and
there's all these like sad realizations
about
the state of the mandalorians how did
you feel watching that unfold
you know i know the story so well now
that there is a part of me
that feels crazy
there's a part of me that feels like a
mandalorian like i've lived this story
for so long
i feel the pain of of you know mandalore
and and the homeworld and this struggle
um and i i i have lived here so long
that it it does feel quite emotional for
me when i hear about
the the state of things not only that
and then you see
moth gideon busting through a tie
fighter with your
dark saber i know i was like screaming
at the tv when i saw that
i was like he doesn't even look good
holding it
that's mine when you saw that were you
worried about
bogatan's fate because there was a lot
of theories that maybe moff gideon
killed her in a battle or something i
know there are a lot of theories
and you know what we there is a story
there and we will find
out but i would hate to ruin it for
anyone okay
good to know because i'm like if she's
one and done i'm out of here
[Laughter]
you'll just have to wait and see i would
you know as a fan of the show
i hate spoilers and so that is also that
has been the thing that's kept me
really good on social media to be honest
is that i didn't want to ruin it for
anyone you know there is
there is teasing something and then
there is ruining it for people and i
really wanted to um
to make sure that i i kept it exciting
for them and i wanted them to live that
moment
for the first time when they see her and
and and have it be everything that they
wanted it to be for 15 years
so did you have questions for for dave
and john about like
where where has she been what has she
been up to
where's my dark saber i had
so many questions and and i still do i
could talk about star wars until the
cows come home
and luckily so could my fiance and so
he actually you know i really wanted to
see how bogatan fit into this world and
it took a lot of conversations and a lot
of
understanding timelines um and
that meant talking to dave and john
quite a bit actually
so um dave filoni is one of the best
people to talk to about this world
though because
he knows it so well i think he you know
eats sleeps and breathes
uh these characters so um yeah
it's it's been really fun and especially
when we were trying to figure out who
beau was you know the three of us would
really pow wow and
and figure out well would she say this
would she walk like this what would she
do
what you know if because we know this
happened
what is that do we sense that in her
voice
in this moment because that happened
eight years ago so
it's really pulling from a vast amount
of source material because she's been
around for so long
i did love hearing her very
sarcastically say this is
i don't know which version of that they
actually
kept so i don't think i've said this is
the way more times
in my entire life i think i said it many
many times
that day trying to you know give options
like what was she thinking what is she
planning where you know what does she
want um
and we'll just all have to wait and find
out what's one thing that you hope is
answered
through the mandalorian about her story
oh my gosh so much so much i think just
like the fans
i want to know i want to know what
happened with that dark saver
yeah that's the one i want to know if
she's going to get it back
she has to right i don't know we'll just
have to wait and see
boca tam lays it out there though she's
like um
go after there's a person named katana
out there well not a person there's
someone named ahsoka tana out there
um and there are rumors that rosario
dawson is playing ahsoka tano
what did you think of that casting when
you heard that i honestly don't know
anything about it you know there's so
many fan casts and so many rumors
surrounding
the mandalorian that some of them are
true some of them aren't so i have no
idea
you know i've never met victoria so i
don't know anything about it
i love the character from clone wars and
rebels so
i would love to see her i would love to
see those two reunite
you know there's a lot of history with
those two um
and um yeah there's a lot of story there
there's a lot of there's a lot of
camaraderie and
and respect but there's also a lot of um
a lot of pain and
and um distrust and and so we'll see
we'll we'll see what happens i'm so
excited if you know if she does show up
well we know she does show up i say as
much since there is so much like
unexplored time for boca tan like
my thought immediately went to like now
that we've seen you live action i'm like
i want
i want to spin off would you be
interested in that
i am i mean who wouldn't right
now i mean come on that's what's so
great about the star wars universe is
there so many different places
to go off and and find there's there's
so many stories and so many interesting
characters to go after that
that you know um you know i have no idea
but
i would love to play this character as
as long as she
she has a story there are a lot of clone
wars characters
that are and and rebels characters that
are out and about in the universe
somewhere but we just don't we haven't
seen them yet so
if you could pluck one to show up
alongside of you
in the mandalorian like who would you
want to manifest
oh my god i do love the character of
sabine
um you know i would also love
to see what bokeh tan's life was like
with satin her sister and what it was
like you know
losing her sister the way that she did
and and for anyone that doesn't know
that you need to go watch clone wars and
rebels
but um you know her life with obi-wan
and things like that i would love
to know what happened with all of that
and how that actually impacted uh
bokutan as a leader
there are quite a few episodes left so
do you think we could see boca tan
coming back
um this season you know i wouldn't want
to spoil anything you'll just have to
watch it
okay i guess i will watch it i mean
since you're gonna do it anyway what do
you think of baby yoda
okay i can't i know baby yoda
like honestly it it's so amazing to me
what they
do with his facial expressions um
you know and and how many people it
takes to control different pieces
of him and the fact that they actually
listen
you know he's miked and i'm miked and
they're
they're listening to me talk to him
there's such a funny little scene where
it wasn't even a scene
i was just sitting there between sets
and
baby is sitting next to me and we just
started having a conversation the guys
operating him
started reacting because they heard me
talking to him like i was talking to him
like he was real and so then they
started reacting
and i had an entire conversation with
baby where his
in all his reactions he was moving his
head and i asked him if he could
to show me his angry face i wanted to
see baby's angry face you know does baby
get angry
and he really tried and he couldn't do
it and then he finally did it and he
looked like a gremlin it was the
funniest thing i've ever seen he looked
like do not give them water or food
after midnight
he went evil and i was like baby oh my
god
well congratulations um this has been so
amazing it's been so amazing to watch
and
i really really hope you get your dark
saber back
wouldn't that be nice it really
complements her
ensemble yes and as a star wars fan you
deserve to be holding that live-action
dark saber
to at least see what it feels like
at some point you know it's it would be
nice it's it's like your own bounce
board
it just it lights up you glow a little
bit i i
think that it would you know i think it
would look very good in her hands but
you never know i
you never know what's gonna happen so
we'll just have to wait and see
you